- Let's watch another episode
of Strange Addictions.
Huge thank you to Thrive Market
for sponsoring this
video, let's get started.
Be whoop!
- I'm addicted to coffee enemas.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] For the past two years,
Trina hasn't been able to function
without her daily coffee enemas,
a procedure where liquid is injected
into the colon to clean
out the lower intestine.
Her addiction is so intense,
she does up to four every day.
- Okay, let's just do
it right off the bat.
Coffee enemas have not been proven to help
with any medical condition.
In like the sixties, seventies,
we used to say maybe for constipation,
but that's been dropped
from medical literature.
We have so many better ways
of handling constipation
that this is largely unnecessary.
They're saying coffee enemas
are used to clean in your colons.
No, they're not.
It's a self cleansing part of the body.
- My initial reaction was
"My God, that's disgusting."
- Pretty judgemental response.
- I tried it and now I'm
addicted to coffee enemas.
- Oh.
- [Narrator] Two years ago,
Trina turned to this unconventional ritual
after a series of health issues.
- I had a lot of stomach
problems, digestive problems,
problems with my kidney, my liver.
I started to do research,
and it led me into the coffee enemas.
And immediately I really
started to feel the benefits.
- It's understandable, someone
that is having symptoms,
who's struggling looking
to find answers online,
finds a treatment that
is within their grasp,
something that they can do
on their own and tries it.
That doesn't mean it's the right treatment
or it's something that
most people should try.
My concern is that there's
something else going on
in these people's bodies
that can be missed
and potentially get worse over time
because they're not seeing a doctor.
Problems with kidneys
needs to be investigated.
'Cause if kidneys start failing,
that's a threat to your own life.
- My name is Julius.
(upbeat music)
I'm 62 years old, and
I'm addicted to balloons.
- I love balloons.
(balloons pop)
- [Julius] They're beautiful.
They're soft, smooth, delicate.
I have a connection with 'em.
- Is this like gonna be
similar to what we've seen
in the previous episodes
of like objectophilia,
or even animism, where you believe
that certain physical inanimate objects
have a soul or a spirit,
or maybe you become even
sexually attracted to them,
I'm curious.
- [Narrator] Now Julius
has filled his home
with over 50,000 balloons.
- 50,000, that's a lot of balloons.
- [Narrator] And he can't sleep
unless he's surrounded by them.
- [Julius] My favorite
is the spherical ones.
- Honestly, I don't see
what's wrong with this yet.
He likes decorating his
house with balloons.
Some people like painting their walls.
I don't know.
They put wallpaper up.
Some people put paper on their walls.
To each their own.
- [Narrator] But Julius's
obsession with balloons
goes beyond shapes and colors.
- My love for balloons,
it's also a sexual love.
- Oh, objectophilia.
(low tempo music)
- [Julius] When I see a beautiful balloon,
my heart starts to
flutter and I get aroused.
I'll take a 12 inch, and
I'll inflate it to 11 inch.
That way it can take a lot of abuse.
- There's a potential connection
between objectophilia,
animism, and autism,
that one study tried to explore.
And, and I'm interested
in exploring that subject
to see how connected
those two conditions are.
- My wife thinks it's
strange, but she accept it.
(upbeat music)
- Again, like you have a
job, you have a partner,
you live a good life, you
take care of your health,
and you're sexually attracted to balloons.
(balloons pop)
Not really a disorder.
Disorders are based on ability
to perform life functions,
get satisfaction in life,
reach goals in life.
Let him sit in his room
and blow up balloons
and squeeze 'em, like what's the,
why, why is he even a,
a thing on this show?
It's kind of weird.
More power to you, sir.
(voices cheer)
Back to the show in just a second.
But first let me tell
you about Thrive Market,
an online marketplace
where you can save money
and get amazing products.
I've personally worked with
Thrive Market for years,
and we teamed up again this April
for Earth Month because
they sell thousands
of my favorite products from
the best eco-friendly brands
like Chomps, Amy's, Gaia Herbs, and more.
Everything they offer is
either ethically sourced,
sustainably farmed, or
regeneratively grown.
So what you get is better
for you, and the planet.
With Thrive Market, you can shop
and sort by the values
that matter most to you,
fair trade certified, gluten free, vegan,
you name it and all orders
$49 more are shipped free
and delivered with carbon neutral shipping
from their zero waste warehouses.
Small, sustainable steps
can lead to a big impact
and make positive change for our climate.
And that's why I use Thrive Market,
and I hope you do too.
Choose whatever membership
best fits your lifestyle,
one month or 12 month packages.
for me, the 12 month
package at just $5 a month
is really a reasonable choice,
and that's the one I recommend
to my friends and family.
Join Thrive Market today and get 40% off
your first order and a
free gift worth over $50.
All you have to do is visit the link
down below, ThriveMarket.com/DoctorMike.
Remember Doctor spelled out,
all right let's get back to the show.
- I'm addicted to butt injections.
(dramatic musical score)
- I'm curious if this is butt injections
through like a BBL where
they do liposuction
then reinject the fat.
- [Narrator] Karmello's
had 54 butt injections,
yet she's never bared her
behind to a plastic surgeon.
(dramatic music)
She receives her shots on the black market
getting pumped with an
unregulated substance
that's been known to include
metal lubricant and cement.
- Yeah, I mean, that's really dangerous.
There's so that can go wrong here.
This isn't a traditional BBL.
Even BBLs are dangerous.
Like one in 3000 individuals who has a BBL
has a complication of a fatty embolism.
The fat actually gets lodged
into their blood vessels
and can be lethal if it travels
all the way up to the lungs.
I've actually had patients
that have had huge, huge complications
as a result of bad injections like this.
They were done abroad in other countries,
but then they ended up
getting a terrible cellulitis,
abscess formation in the buttock area
where like major surgery had to take place
to take out the necrotic
tissue, dead tissue.
So they ended up losing
a part of their buttock.
- What brings you in today?
- Dr. Youn!
Welcome back to the channel.
- Do you have any idea
what she injected you with?
Did she tell you?
- She said
a liquid silicone.
- [Dr. Youn] Okay.
- But I'm not sure if
that's really what it was.
- Did she do anything afterwards?
I mean, did she stitch up the incisions?
- She put super glue.
- There are times we use
glue in medical settings,
in the ER, but not for deep wounds,
not for big wounds, not for wounds
that could potentially
become severely infected.
So like there's a time and
place for all medical tools.
And that's not the place for super glue.
- You could see here, this is your thigh
the fat in your thigh,
which is smooth and normal.
But up here it looks kind of spongy,
this texture and and that's
definitely not normal.
So even though you're healthy,
it just takes one bad injection
to literally kill you.
(dramatic music)
- Oh, that's good.
I'm glad she was able to
decide not to do that again.
- My name is Casie.
I'm 26 years old.
I'm from Fayetteville, Tennessee,
and I'm addicted to carrying
around my husband's urn.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Their marriage
was picture perfect,
until Sean suffered a severe asthma attack
two months ago.
- [Narrator] Two months ago, it's recent.
Why, why are they not letting this woman
bereave in peace, like?
- [Narrator] Her addiction
has recently evolved.
(dramatic music)
- I guess, with the
transfer of his cremains,
you know, some got into
the cardboard box as well.
And they spilled out on my hands.
And I didn't wanna wipe,
wipe him off 'cause I that's my husband,
I don't wanna wipe him away.
So I just licked it off my fingers.
- Infectious disease
wise, it's her husband.
So very low risk there.
And the, the body's been cremated.
So all infectious diseases would
essentially be wiped out as well.
- It tastes like rotten
eggs, sand, and sandpaper,
but I've grown to love that taste.
- I wonder if there's a, a
pica condition here happening.
- I'm a little bit concerned
about what's in embalming fluid,
and I'm a little bit concerned
about how much of those
chemicals are in those ashes.
- Oh, I did not know
that that was the case.
If there was embalming fluid used,
formaldehyde is the main
ingredient in embalming fluid,
and that is very lethal.
I think one ounce of formaldehyde
can be lethal to your lungs,
throat, nervous system.
Like there's a lot of issues with that.
And then the other
ingredients in embalming fluid
is like methanol, ethanol,
things that can lead
to blindness, brain damage.
Like that's a really serious concern.
- If you are trying to deal
with the reality of this,
and to help yourself,
I'm afraid that you're
not gonna be able to,
as long as you're eating the ashes
because you're eating a substance
that would make you
lose touch with reality.
(dramatic music)
- I think that's probably
ideal for her own safety.
At that point, it definitely took a turn
from carrying her husband's ashes,
which I find not to be a medical issue,
to her consuming embalming fluid and ashes
that could become a medical issue.
And it's something that
threatens her life.
And now, now it's become a disorder.
(click sound effect)
- My name is Margaret,
(upbeat music)
and I'm 53 years old.
I live in Morning View, Kentucky
and I'm addicted to
stinging myself with bees.
- Ooh!
(dramatic music)
Kind of mean to the bee,
'cause doesn't the bee
die after it stings you?
- [Narrator] Margaret has been addicted
to bee stings for the past 10 years.
- [Margaret] Okay.
- It could be an endorphin rush,
because when you do experience pain
when your body tries to relieve that pain,
it sends endorphins to
try and decrease the pain.
- [Narrator] Her addiction
started innocently,
as a way to relieve her arthritis.
- You know, there is some
preliminary evidence,
weak evidence I would call it,
of bee venom helping individuals
with rheumatoid and osteoarthritis.
However, when you compare
it to the treatments
that we have now, you
can get better outcomes
with less side effects,
and most importantly, less pain.
- [Margaret] The first
time that I stung myself,
it didn't hurt as bad
as I thought it would.
And it just got easier every time.
- And it's great that she
doesn't have a bee allergy.
I mean some individuals, they get stung,
their whole arm blows up.
Their mouth can even blow up.
They can go into anaphylaxis.
People carry EpiPens for bees.
And you know, even though allergies
are more likely to happen early in life,
they can develop later in life as well.
- [Narrator] But every time
Margaret stings herself,
the honey bee dies.
- Yeah.
- [Narrator] Something
Margaret is all too aware of.
- Every bee is precious.
I get sad when I watch 'em die.
I prefer to get a older bee.
The younger bees, they've
got their lives ahead of them
and it helps me feel less
guilt about killing the bees.
(upbeat music)
- It's a sad situation to
see because I would love
for her to find pain relief in a way
where it's not damaging to the bees,
to her mental health and potentially
gives her, can give her
longer lasting relief
depending on what the
cause of her arthritis is.
Did you hear about the
Japanese eyeball licking trend?
That's right.
Click here for my full
video talking all about it.
You're gonna learn a lot.
Thanks again to Thrive Market
for sponsoring this video.
Join Thrive Market today and get 40% off
your first order and a
free gift worth over $50.
Use my link to get started.
As always stay happy and healthy.